Science doesn’t lie, but scientists… that’s
a different story.
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews. The American
Statistical Association recently released
a statement reminding scientists what the
P value stands for… along with six guiding
principles on what determines statistical
significance. Why? Because scientists and
organizations might be gaming the system to
get results published, get funding, or generally
advance their career. But before we get into
that, let’s explain what they’re messing
with -- the thing called the P Value.
It all has to do with how scientific experiments
work. As you know, many studies use a control
group and an experimental group. The experimental
group gets a pill, treatment, or some other
thing that scientists want to know more about
whereas the control group does not - it’s
just there as a comparison. This is where
the P value comes in. It helps us determine
whether any differences found between the
two groups are due to random chance, sampling
error, or the actual thing the scientists
were testing.
The p-value is the probability that you would
get the observed results (or something more
extreme) if there is no real difference between
groups. It ranges from 0-1, and the general
rule seems to be that the lower the P value,
the better.
Hypothetically, getting a P Value of 1 would
mean the results are definitely based on something
other than what you’re testing. A P Value
of 0 would be the results are definitely based
on what you’re testing. But these are the
extremes and generally not seen in studies;
In practice, anything less than .05 is considered
statistically significant.
The problem is there is an overemphasis on
P values. The American Statistical Association
put out the statement clarifying the P value
because as the ASA’s executive director,
Ron Wasserstein remarks, "The p-value was
never intended to be a substitute for scientific
reasoning."
This is a big deal because it’s having serious
consequences in our knowledge and understanding.
It means we might be neglecting important
and crucial areas of research. In practice,
it could mean we have a decreased understanding
of the true effect of a treatment or medication...
Because the overemphasis on P value often
leads to the neglect of other information
in studies - such as effect size.
If you're a drug manufacturer and you have
a hair growth drug that you want to market.
You conduct a study, and it comes up with
a P value of .05. Great. It means that there
is a small probability that an outside force
was responsible for the hair growth. So you’ll
buy that pill, right?
But hold on. What was ignored was the effect
size. What the P value is not telling us is
that those bald guys only grew 2 hairs and
not a full, luscious mane. So, technically,
they’re still bald. This is part of the
problem. We shouldn’t be putting all our
faith in this one number. But scientists often
are, so much so that they might be skewing
their experiments to get lower Ps.
Just like teachers teach to the test, scientists
design experiments to get the lowest possible
P at the expense of solid scientific reasoning
and investigation. Or after their experiment
is conducted, they select the specific analysis
methods that are more likely to lead to statistically
significant results and/or cherry pick which
results to include or leave out.
So, why are scientists doing this? Well, that,
of course, cannot be answered with certainty;
but, it is telling that statistically significant
effects are much more likely to be published.
Researchers Sullivan and Feinn found that
the number of studies published that contain
P values in their abstracts has doubled from
1990 to 2014, and of those studies that included
a P value, 96% were below .05. Getting published
can play a huge role in career advancement...in
the halls of academia, it’s either “Publish
or Perish.” So the Association’s recent
statement is more than just about statistical
analysis - more than just about reproducibility
and replication. It’s about how and what
the scientific community values, redefining
these and moving away from a binary system
of statistical significance to one that views
evidence on a continuum.
But, this is just one way that science is
failing us. Check out Dr. Kiki Sanford’s
episode for her top 5 list on what’s wrong
with science, here.
What is something you’d love to research?
Or have us research for ya?
Let us know in the comments and remember to
subscribe so you never miss an episode of
DNews. Thanks for watching.